in the lobby of Ramsey solutions teri is
with us I Terry how are you good how are
you doing today better than I deserve
welcome where are you from Centerville
Ohio very cool and that is near dayton
dayton okay very cool and you're here to
do a debt free scream i am i love how
much have you paid off 96 thousand
dollars
boom look at you i love it how long did
that take about two and a half years
hard work huh it was oh my I'm a single
mom this is my daughter Janelle okay hey
hey Janelle welcome glad you could come
with your mom and cheer her on excellent
you've probably been cheering her on for
two and a half years haven't you yeah
I'll bet a bet so Terry what was your
range of income through this two and a
half year period when I started I was a
active-duty Air Force and I was making
about $80,000 a year during the time
that I did this I did retire when went
with only my retire and income for a few
months and then was hired back on so I'm
currently gonna make over $140,000 Wow
look at you and you're back in the Air
Force I'm active duty civilian sorry I'm
a civilian government civilian you said
Hart back on I didn't know what you're
making okay that's a billion very cool
very cool
well nice move little step down to take
a big step forward it's worked out well
I guess and thank you for your service
very cool so how long were you in the
Air Force
24 years oh so you got the 20-year
retirement yes nice check coming in yes
and then got the job and that goes with
it to make the 140 yes very cool good
for you very good so what kind of debt
was this 96 thousand dollars I had a car
loan that was over 20 thousand when we
started but I mean the vast majority of
it was a credit card debt um probably
over half of it was credit card debt I
owed money to some friends I had a TSP
loan I had gosh just about everything
except for a student loan really you
were fairly normal
I was very normal unfortunately except
that you were a single mom making 80k
yeah yes cool what did you do when you
were in the Air Force what was your job
in the Air Force logistics ah
very good okay
so how often did you move we were
ranging around three to four years um
and when I moved out to Ohio it was to
go to the Air Force Institute of
Technology oh yeah competitive master's
program neat and I separated with her
dad at that time and we eventually
divorced and he lives nearby and West
Virginia and so Ohio works well for her
to the old finish out school and stay
close to her dad yeah
good very cool good so that's what broke
loose two and a half years ago then that
was when I was really like I'm I'm a
little out of control um he had already
retired and so because I was still
active duty they make him a paycheck I
ended up with the majority of the debt
out of the divorce and unfortunate
really forced me to kind of pay
attention but to be honest that first
year I did a lot of what you call is
that entitlement I make the money I am
single now I'm going to just and didn't
have fun and you know we loved it and it
wasn't reality we couldn't continue a
life like that and uh when Disneyland is
not real you have to go home at the end
of the vacation that was a metaphor okay
that's funny and eventually I had a
friend loan me a total money makeover
book and it just it was exactly the
right time I really needed to see that
you were coming home from the Veit the
grown-up vacation land of healing a
little after the divorce and
overspending and then go okay I'm gonna
now I got it now I got a saddle up here
and take this take care of business
exactly and it was the baby steps that
kind of gave me the pathway to finding
my way forward and a little bit of my
own where do I want to go after being
married for a long time but now I'm on
my own and what is my vision am I dream
for myself and they really gave me the
path to go away mmm very cool so how
hard is this two and a half years been
it's been very hard when I never had to
Kelly about my experience that's when I
realized how much life had actually
happened
um I first tried it
August 2013 was when I read the book and
I stopped some envelopes for the very
first time and then I have my car broken
into and my purse stolen and all that
cash was gone and it really kind of sent
me back because I didn't even have baby
step one Don yet but I had a good friend
at a local church she blessed us with a
Walmart gift card and Financial Peace
University Wow so when I came out of
Financial Peace University in October
2013 I was ready I was ready to start
baby step one and that's when I found
out my mom had pancreatic cancer oh my
gosh and she had emergency surgery in
November 13 and when you're a military
family and you're away from I grew up in
Washington State
when I'm a long ways from home so just
the Vegas so uh I had to take out an Air
Force Aid Society loan because I didn't
even have baby step one fully done yet
in order to go home both in November and
December and it was it was very
difficult to really kind of set us back
and then you got started yeah I do
exactly and I just never thought of it
that way and then I deployed to East
Africa in April of 2014 and was gone for
six and a half months and when you're
gone like that and you're trying to
budget for your family back home and the
caregivers who are taking care of her
it's what's hard it's really hard to
budget for a household that you're not
in anymore so I just kept plugging away
at the debt came back we fell off the
wagon at that time I went to Disney
World
um because that was the one-year
anniversary and my mom staff and I had
just gotten home from being gone and
then that's when I retired and I went a
month without a paycheck whatsoever and
that's when I got really serious and
that's when that's when the two and a
half years started right then yeah it
started out at the end of 2013
so we just kept plugging along and that
was really out of two and a half years
you weren't really good at it for 18
months really you've been really good at
it for about a year I assisted some you
were good I tell them that you a month
that you say you
not in my existing through just
truckloads of crap but I can say that
are you really you're amazing at getting
back up I mean as far as efficiency goes
with the math you really have only had
one good year yes that's exactly it you
pour it up in one year big time yes I
mean because what I'm saying is
mathematically what you're telling me
the story you told me almost all that 96
happened in a year didn't it and just
most of it last year yes exactly that's
what yeah that's the story I thought I
heard exactly and that was you know the
beginning of last year started out with
ramen noodles which she used to love and
now she doesn't like ramen you should
you know you always have to have some
kind of broke people food that reminds
you of back in the day that way you
could when you're an old lady you could
tell your grandkids back in the day
you'll tell your grandkids that story
that's how that you got to have Brooke
people food in your life somewhere for
us it was teen it was tuna fish we hate
tuna fish because we ate tuna fish soggy
sandwiches I still can't stand tuna fish
Erin thinks it's health food I think
it's broken people food but yeah it just
you got to have something that reminds
you of that stuff and you're struggling
you fight through and the good news is
with as much manure as you swam through
to get to this point you can do anything
mylord saving money and becoming a
millionaire it's nothing now I mean you
paid almost $100,000 in one frickin year
pretty nice I mean seriously it's just
so easy yeah so you could do anything
you can do anything and you know how to
get back up most people never learn that
scale lets them that's a highly
developed skill of successful people and
that's exactly my message particularly
for single parents out there we're
trying to go through this you're gonna
fall but just pick it back up and dust
that budget off again and fix it up
again try again next month don't give up
you can do it yeah you're an important
important visitor today
you just encouraged some people because
this is just so real it's just dripping
with real it felt pretty it's it's it's
sucked I mean I try to tell people all
the time this getting out
that thing is not fine it's just fun
when you get there now you don't have
any payment you got $140,000 income yeah
alright ninety six thousand dollars paid
off in two and a half years Terry and
Janelle Dayton Ohio make an ad now
making 140 great story count it down
let's hear a debt free scream three two
one that's how it happens that's how you
do it
that's real this is the Dave Ramsey show
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show and say you have to break the
cycle you have to flip this thing on its
head and make it behave you've got to
get so fired up and wired up that you're
broke friends think you've lost your
mind